this is great this is great this is what
a girl is about to judge the appearance
those millionaires look like while doing
it guys
guys I know you still sit about the
Halal elem thing but like comment hi my
name is Purcell you do not know now you
know your life is different now the
Oscars happened and so I'm going to
review the fashions because this has
become a thing that I do now I have a
thing on YouTube that I do I talk about
gown alright I'll just get into it
Halle Berry oh wow wow that's going on
up step like a bold choices
this look is like buying ten dollars for
the Taco Bell and then going out to a
club and dancing all night it's a bold
choice lots of risk involved I like this
my eyeballs might be having tiny
features for the donor exactly wants to
stop and look at and focus on
everything's good I think everything's
good I think everything's good I mean
the more I look at it may I have doubts
but I'm going to move on quickly
kate mckinnon ah you look so beautiful
and young and fresh and like you're
doing a parody of a covergirl commercial
but you're actually beautiful and you're
so funny oh god damn and you look like
you're having fun and a best accessory
you can bring to a red carpet event with
you as a smile and uh airplane bottle of
vodka
Viola Davis oh you look so chic and
beautiful and you make that Justin
Bieber hairdo look good I'm just trying
to keep up Jenny this is very sleek but
the top is interesting it looks like
your dress isn't trying to tie you up in
it
because it doesn't want you to leave
cute ryan gosling this is cute
I like when men do something more
interesting than just your average
tuxedo and this really little
sophisticated dumb and Dumberer
ensemble s thing is cute I have to like
v post you look very angry and calm at
the same time brie Larson why so still
treat there's like a oil spills like
cascading all over your body and you're
so turned on by it
you also look a little sleepy and I'm
only saying that because I am really
sleepy so I feel like I have
an ability to notice that in other I'm
sure you've noticed that about me around
the Chopra where did you get that fancy
quilt to make a do address am i back in
10th grade math class because this is
very geometric I think this is really
cool it's like your boobs are hiding
behind a fence on the top half of your
body and it's like no one will know
we're here cute chilly Sauron well this
looks like beautiful surprise Wow I'm
shocked or for the background I would
think that this is an older photo that
you've worn something similar to this
but I think it's just because you always
look pretty all the time forever this
was like a very sleek accordion all over
your body
cute Emma Stone yeah I mean let's all
just collectively puke and breathe and
say [ __ ] you can retire now as greatest
human just so you know it must be
exhausting nicole kidman whoo you look
naked with Tim Hannah all over your body
but it's not it's a dress I think I like
this but I also think this might be
enough the most flattering color unless
you want it to look completely naked it
might also be the photo this might be a
different color in real life but the
dress is done name I love it I would
wear this to bed and I mean that in a
compliment because the bed is like the
fastest place that I go to on a regular
pace Salma Hayek okay you look like
you're going to a really beautiful
wedding funeral and you might be the
bride or you might be the mistress
no one knows Scarlett Johansson I don't
hate this harkens back to when I was in
fourth grade and they taught us how to
juggle with scarves in gym class why was
that a lesson we learned in gym class we
learned to the juggle with scarves in
gym the class is supposed to teach you
about health and fitness Joe Williams oh
this is always so pretty yours look so
demure and scared elegantly frightened
and sophisticated sleep fragile cute
Dakota Johnson let's sell out a dress
Wow and I can't not look directly at the
vagina area
I think it's the point of this dress it
seems like there's a bow situation
happening massively over the vaginal
region as if your cooter was a gift to
all of us there's still very eighties to
me but I like this dress I mean you guys
know me I love any clothes that cover my
body from head-to-toe messes getting out
here Janelle Monae whoa I know Janelle
Monae on all right carpets you guys know
this already
she takes passionate and she's so cool
regardless of whether people think
there's good fashion risk I love them
this one is cool birds going to battle
on your breath Wow how you always work
black and white is basically just a
walking into the grand theme oh this is
an anti hug dress people can't get to
you if your dress is that big now I love
it more also you get the pose like a
cake topper all night yeah baby Teigen
all right please sexy sophisticated a
little [ __ ] but in a good way always
they're having a good time I like at one
point I need to cut away to Gemma's in
the audience and she was resting on the
children looks like she was sleeping and
I thought that was funny because she's
just real just like a Jessica Biel oh
this is cool or in your body damn - this
looks like it was just a full glitter
dress and then you got a couple kids
before you decide to walk on the red
carpet they just hug you with their
cloth it's really interesting to look at
looks like you have like a necklace with
my hair on it Octavia Spencer oh this is
so pretty
it's like mother of the bride up top and
then like party princess Kenton Yetta on
the bottom and I'm into that combo it is
really cool and I don't know what else
to say about it you seem really lovely
I'm wonderful if you'd ever like give me
just some real maternal advice about the
industry I'll gladly take it this got
off topic I'll let you go okay talk to
you soon you're done oh good we got a
mullet dress short in the front long
what
are you offended by my gosh this looks
really cute and pretty and elegant and
you have pockets we lose our finishing
mine over pockets and dresses I don't
know why I think it's a chromosomal
thing for us but we can hide all of our
secrets in there Tyrell like Janelle
Monae
love everything Pharrell wears because
it's just cool and interesting he's got
this seeming demeanor that you can say
any thing about his what he's wearing
but he'll never affect him it's like a
golf matador that like stop it Claire's
your mom on the way of the red carpet
and never having like a ten necklaces
with the price of one sale and it was I
can't have that up here's Jennifer
Goodwin oh this is pretty
are you seem disappointed by it it looks
itchy is that why you look sad --is-- is
it itchy
it looks itchy but it's pretty but it's
probably itchy yeah it's itchy I'm sorry
you know stop it
haha this is a citizen's arrest I'm
arresting you you're arresting me yes
that's actually the more accurate thing
here you're arresting me with your looks
and your sense of just pure confidence I
am my heart if I should be six obsessed
about matter IVP answered and this is
sexy elegant did we fill up the tank
cause Vavoom oh this is giving me the
classiest boner I've ever had thank you
Emma Roberts Wow this is sexy sultry
pretty elegant I'm just recycling a lot
of the same as inches because this looks
good I don't know what to say
Victorian Jessica Rabbit cute ruth negga
wow this looks like grandma pajamas but
like really sexy grandma pajamas and you
look like you're gonna haunt my dreams
doing a haunted Victorian at all really
pretty Naomi Harris
oh this is interesting this is another
party mullet dress but not really this
is like a dress of the Cape whoa and
it's really modest but it's also not
that modest your shoes are cool I never
noticed shoes those are great shoes oh
and your hair is really sleek it's like
your hair started on your head and then
somehow and then your back turned into a
cape and ran down the back your legs ah
magic cue Hailee Steinfeld Steinfeld
turn feels dirty
meaning teeny-tiny dresses not that
dress that's a big dress it's got a lot
on it but your face is beautiful and
that's all I got to say about that when
I go that's my assessment of the red
carpet looks at the Oscars this year let
me know what you guys thought who is
your favorite look and if I missed any
that you really love let me know spec
definitely did that and give this video
a thumbs up if you want more fashion
review type of videos cuz I really enjoy
doing them and I'm a style icon so it
could be a disservice not to do them and
if you haven't already click this one
and subscribe to this YouTube channel I
make videos Monday Wednesday and Friday
mostly ish I will see you next time uh
no no Leslie man that's a lot of dress
this also takes me back to elementary
school gym class when we did the
parachute which also leads me to the
question why did they teach us how to
use a parachute in gym class a class
that should be about health a business
and we juggle scars and just wish the
parachute system